after 911 dozens of state-run quote
unquote fusion centers popped up all
over the country now there are roughly
79 of them in operation and they exist
in virtually every state the point of
these centers is supposedly to
facilitate cooperation between the
federal government and the states in
order to gather intelligence and prevent
terrorist attacks and other serious
threats to the Homeland but here's the
strange thing uh they don't appear to be
doing that a couple years ago
investigative reporters at the nation
found that the fusion Center in Central
Florida was investigating quote criminal
and violent extremist use of emojis the
Fort Worth Fusion Center meanwhile was
preoccupied with a plot to break the
Netflix star Joe Exotic out of prison
while the capitol region Fusion Center
was busy looking into viral Tick Tock
challenges the Washington State Fusion
Center for its part opened an
investigation into a report quote
concerning a homeowner working on cars
in his driveway and letting oil run down
the street into Mission Creek in
Olympia now in any other context
this would be considered fraud these
state governments are taking money to
fight terrorism but they're not remotely
attempting to do that in fact they don't
appear to be doing anything of
consequence whatsoever which in this
context is especially strange I mean
normally when federal and state
governments give themselves vast powers
of surveillance and lofty new mandates
they don't waste their time chasing down
homeowners who are being a little sloppy
while they work on their cars they
usually start using their expanded
Powers as quickly and as widely as
possible so one of two things is
happening here either these fusion
centers are a massive and long-standing
fraud or there's something else going on
here or a little bit of both now for a
while now there there have been signs
that the latter explanation something
else is going on here is the more
plausible one in their investigation the
nation obtained documentation indicating
that one area of focus for these fusion
centers is quote First Amendment
protected events but the journalists
weren't able to provide much more
Clarity on that probably because the
government redacted information on their
investigations in this area so we
learned all about the Tik Tock
investigations and the Emoji
investigations at these fusion centers
but not so much about their Crackdown on
the First Amendment and that's where
things have stood for the past several
years but yesterday thanks to a report
from Mary Margaret olahan at the daily
signal we have indication of the actual
mission of these fusion centers and what
First Amendment protected events they
might be interested in the daily signal
obtained an email sent in February of
2023 by the Anti-Defamation League or
the ADL to the Washington State Fusion
Center that's the same Fusion Center
that was looking into that homeowner who
was working on his car in a sloppy way
uh here's the subject line white
supremacist fight clubs anti-lgbtq plus
hate now in the body of the email the
ADL warns about quote online amplifiers
of lgbtq plus hate promoting quote false
narratives escalating harassment of
lgbtq plus individuals this alleged hate
includes quote the vilification of drag
shows and quot baseless claims of child
Grooming by lgbtq plus people according
to the adl's email to this Washington
State counterterrorism Center this
vilification quote further endangered
and isolated and already at risk
Community according to the Daily signal
the email then appears to link to an ADL
blog post which identifies the who the
the the purveyors of this supposedly d
ous hate are and uh those people are uh
Libs of Tik Tok the account gays against
groomers Blaze media Christopher rufo
and of course that International
Infamous terrorist who goes by the name
Matt Walsh now the post states that
quote the ADL is advocating for
government Partners to strengthen laws
against perpetrators of online hate as
well as Consulting with law enforcement
Partners to act on online hate speech
that incites violence Andor credible
threats the ADL says that it teamed up
with a glad as well and they're
apparently all working with law
enforcement in other words the ADL just
to get you up to speed here the ADL told
a counterterrorism agency to investigate
journalists and political commentators
because we are saying things they don't
like they tried they they are TR trying
explicitly to use the arm of the law to
silence us at
gunpoint now they don't even claim that
we violated any law right they're not
claiming that because we we haven't
instead they're saying that because we
oppose the chemical and physical
castration of children and because we
believe in biology and because we don't
think that men should be cross-dressing
in front of children therefore we are
inciting violence so they call on law
enforcement to act the daily signal
reached out to the Washington State uh
State Patrol about this and they're one
of the state agencies that participated
in this Fusion Center they indicated
that they take emails from the ad L and
various other interest groups under
advisement but they denied opening any
investigation on the basis of the adl's
email so according to them as far as we
know there is not a current criminal
investigation against say me for
tweeting things that they don't like now
obviously we have no idea whether that's
true or not we also have no reason to
believe that it's true um you know it'
certainly be strange for the ADL to send
an email like this to a counterterrorism
center if they thought it would just be
ignored
right the fact that they're sending it
would seem to indicate that there's some
kind of relationship here there's some
sort of precedent using the internet
without Express V pan it's like leaving
your keys in your car while you run into
the gas station for a snack most of the
time you're probably fine but what if
you come back to see someone driving off
with your car every time you connect to
an unencrypted Network in cafes hotels
or airports any hacker on the same
network can gain access to your personal
data which uh such as your password
Financial details and so much more
doesn't take much technical knowledge to
hack somebody all the hacker needs is
some cheap Hardware where hackers can
make up to $1,000 per person selling
personal information on the dark web
Express VN creates a secure encrypted
tunnel between your device and the
internet so hackers can't steal your
sensitive data it take a hacker with a
supercomputer over a billion years to
get past Express vpn's encryption I love
how easy to use it is to use uh Express
Vin all you got to do is fire up the app
click one button to get protected it
works on all devices your phone laptop
tablets and more secure your online data
today by visiting expressvpn.com
that's
expressvpn.com Walsh you can get an
extra 3 months free expressvpn.com
Walsh we also have no idea how many
similar emails the ADL has sent to this
particular Fusion Center or any others
what we do know is that the ADL has a
very long history of not simply advising
law enforcement agencies which they
shouldn't even be doing that but
participating directly in law
enforcement functions this is a quote
from a speech that James Comey who was
the FBI director of the time delivered
to the the adl's Leadership Summit back
in 2014 quote the FBI works at the ADL
to host civil rights and hate crime
training for our state and local
counterparts through a number of
programs and the ADL of course has even
greater reach you trained more than
12,000 law enforcement Personnel last
year
alone and I want to thank you for
that so this is not a typical political
nonprofit we're talking about here the
gdl is conducting training for law
enforcement agencies including the
FBI and these Partnerships have only
accelerated in recent years post BLM as
the ADL States on his website quote in
2020 Alone adl's Center for extremism
provided law enforcement with critical
intelligence about extremism over a
thousand times and tracked over 5,000
new incidents of hate on our online
interactive heat
map in other words the ADL which
supposedly was founded to combat
anti-Semitism is now a deao Intelligence
Agency for federal and state law
enforcement this is the organization
that's now advising the Washington
Fusion Center to investigate me and
several other commentators for having
offensive
opinions now if you know anything about
the history of the ADL this actually
probably wouldn't surprise you the ADL
has a long and well documented history
of working with law enforcement even
going so far is to actively participate
in law enforcement investigations one of
the more famous cases took place in the
1960s when an ADL director raised money
for the FBI to pay some clansmen $36,000
in an effort to set up other clansmen
now that incident led to a shootout and
a death of the death of one clan member
whatever you make of that operation
journalists noted at the time that it
was obviously a little strange for a
private tax exempt organization to be
involved in this the ACLU at the time
called for an
investigation but in the end no one
seemed to mind the ADL adopted a pseudo
law enforcement assistant role which
they've retained ever
since now I focused on the ADL so far
mainly because they're the group they're
that are trying to have me specifically
investigated but uh there are many other
organizations like the ADL doing the
same thing maybe the most notable is the
Southern Poverty Law Center or splc you
might remember that the FBI cited the
splc in its Infamous memo uh claiming
that quote radical traditionalist
Catholic ideology is a significant
terrorist threat in America the FBI
tried to hide that memo but a
whistleblower came forward and released
it um the the splc is a completely
discredited group they've even had to
pay out defamations settlements for some
of their more egregious hack jobs and
the bureau knows that according to the
Whistleblower but the FBI tried to cite
them anyway in order to justify the
targeted surveillance of Catholics on
the basis of their religious
beliefs we've seen many examples of
similar misconduct in recent years in
which the government partners with some
supposedly independent private entity in
order to lend some legitimacy to its
obviously illegitimate investigations
during the Trump campaign the FBI
effectively teamed up with the
Washington Post in order to obtain
secret surveillance warrants against the
Trump team the FBI even copy pasted from
a debunked Washington Post editorial in
its fisa warrant application against
Carter page and more recently the doj
has been investigating Dr Ethan hay uh
because he blew the whistle on Texas
Children's Hospital which claimed which
claimed that it had stopped butchering
children uh but kept on doing it anyway
in secret and that got the attention of
trans activists and their various
advocacy groups which in turn led to the
doj knocking on H's door now they know
they don't have a legal case against him
they know it's not a violation of
patient privacy to disclose the
existence of unlawful and unethical
procedures without disclosing patient
identities but they're harassing him
anyway they want to send him to prison
take away his medical
license now it's not hard to see where
all this leads as I told the daily
signal um when they called me to about
this story to get my comment on it
before they published it you know I have
no doubt that if Biden wins another term
we will actually see prominent
conservative commentators arrested on
hate crime and terrorism charges that is
going to happen this is not this is not
hyperbole or or you know being dramatic
conspiracy theories this is what they
want to do and they're laying the
groundwork for it right now first they
open investigations then they start
surveillance and then once that's
normalized they escalate things we
talked about slippery slopes yesterday
on the show in relation to transi ology
and this is yet another slippery slope
that we are on the ADL is telling
government counterterrorism centers to
suppress political
descent and the fact is that unless they
pay a price for this unless there is
enormous
backlash and unless in law enforcement
agencies stop taking marching orders
from these compromised far-left wi
activist
groups then they'll continue to make
these
demands and eventually they'll get what
they want
and at that point if it gets that far
the only real question will be which of
us do they hit first and try to make an
example out of hey YouTube thanks for
listening to the show if you'd like
access to my full show with no ads you
should go to dailywire.com and use promo
code Walsh to get two months free on all
annual plans see you there